Emmanuel Daoud vous êtes avocat
pénaliste spécialisé notamment dans le
droit international la justice des
tribunaux et des cours internationales
elle s'exerce davantage aujourd'hui ou
vous diriez que l'impunité a encore de
très beaux jours devant
elle écoutez je pense qu'elle s'exerce
davantage aujourd'hui pour une raison
simple c'est que les les juristes qu'il
soient avocat avocat ou magistrat sont
d'abord formés initialement à la justice
internationale de façon plus récurrente
et plus approfondie ensuite le monde on
dit qu'on est dans un monde global si on
est dans un monde global on est dans une
justice globale et comme on est de plus
en plus familiarisé avec les outils
internationaux on peut de façon plus
habituelle par exemple saisir la Cour
Pénale international qui semble un grand
machin mais en réalité dès lors que on
veut bien lire le Statut de Rome on
s'aperçoit assez rapidement qu'on peut
s'adresser à cette juridiction sans trop
de difficulté en respectant évidemment
les règles de procédure donc les
juristes aujourd'hui les avocats
aujourd'hui les magistrats aujourd'hui
les victimes
aussi ont tendance à aller devant les
juridictions internationales alors la
lutte contre l'impunité elle doit être
menée et si les crimes les plus graves
disparaissaient par enchaitement on le
saurait et l'actualité récente montre
que ce n'est pas le cas pour être
parfaitement didactique quelle est la
différence entre la CPI la Cour pénale
internationale et le tps le Tribunal
pénal international alors la Cour pénale
internationale elle a son siège à la ha
hm hm et c'est la juridiction qui est la
seule juridiction qui peut juger des
chefs d'État en exercice le Tribunal
Pénal International est un tribunal
pénal international par exemple pour le
Rwanda pour l'exyoslavie qui sont des
créations adoc ad hoc donc la Cour
pénale internationale elle a un siège
permanent et elle peut être saisie en
permanence et elle a des des magistrats
des procureurs des greffiers des
enquêteurs et des des enquêtres qui
peuvent être mobilisé pour enquêter sur
les cinq continents diriez-vous que
c'est une avancée majeure la création de
la CPI il y a 20 ans c'est une avancée
majeure
fondamentale qui a levé beaucoup
d'espoir et qui a déçu énormément aussi
en 20 ans elle a condamné que des
seconds couteaux le bilan est assez
maigre en même temps ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que la justice internationale est
éminemment politique les états
l'utilisent quand ça les sert mais les
cartes dès qu'elles touchent leurs
propres intérêts nous sommes d'accord et
prenons
l'exemple du Conseil de
sécurité ni la Russie ni les États-Unis
ni la Chine ni l'Inde ni Israël Chine ni
l'Inde ni ni Israël non'ont reconnu la
compétence de la Cour pénale
internationale ça veut bien dire qu'il y
a une difficulté les États-Unis l'ont
refusé pourquoi parce que ils mènent
parfois des guerres dont la légitimité
est contestable est contestable ou en
tout cas lorsqu'on bomb e de façon
systématique des populations civiles
s'appelle un crime de guerre ou un crime
contre l'humanité et les États-Unis
n'ont pas euh la volonté de d'être
soumis à ce type de jridiction mais
alors justement comment est-ce qu'on
contourne cette volonté manifeste de ne
pas coopérer avec la justice
internationale B par exemple c'est ce
qu'a fait l'Ukraine elle a reconnu la
compétence pour la la situation qu'elle
vivait alors qu'elle n'avait pas ratifié
le Statut de Rome et donc la Cour pénale
internationale a pu exercer sa
compétence d'autres États je crois 12
États ont aussi déféré devant la coure
pénale internationale la situation et la
guerre commise en Ukraine par par la
Russie donc il y a des des des moyens le
véritable progrès ou plus exactement la
consécration de la Cour pénale
internationale interviendra le jour où
tous les pays reconnaîtront sa
compétence reconnaîtrant sa compétence
où tous les pays et tous les chefs
d'État pourront être poursuivis HM alors
la Cour pénale internationale a lancé un
mandat d'arrêt le 17 mars dernier contre
le président russe Vladimir Poutine
est-ce que c'est la première fois qu'un
chef d'État en exercice membre du
Conseil de sécurité des Nations Unies
est visé par une telle procédure c'est
la première
fois lorsque nous avions saisi en
décembre la COP internationale
s'agissant de la déportation des des
enfants ukrainien si on l'a fait c'est
qu'on y croyait mais je dois être
honnête vis-à-vis de vous nous ne
pensions pas que la Cour pénale
internationale allait réagir aussi vite
effectivement elle a réagi en en 3 mois
à peine c'est un temps record c'est une
surprise pour vous faut-il y voir
justement un un signal contre l'impunité
ou tout simplement une volonté de la
Cour pénale internationale d'asseoir son
autorité alors qu'elle est en perte de
vitesse et de légitimité surtout je
crois que c'est les deux mais aussi ce
que nous avions dit en décembre et que
avec d'autres ONG d'autres avocats et
que nous avons par exemple relayé devant
la Commission des droits de l'homme du
Parlement européen où nous avons pu pu
nous exprimer c'était de dire si vous
voulez lutter contre l'impunité et pour
empêcher qu'on perde la trace de ces
enfants Ukrainiens par milliers dont on
ne savait pas où ils étaient disséminés
sur le territoire russe on parle de
400000 enfants Ukrainiens arrachés à
leur famille ukrainiennne déporté pour
être adopté de force en Russie
exactement avec des modifications du
droit russe qui permettait d'attribuer
un temps record à ces enfants
en 48 he changer leur nom changer leur
nom changer leur lieu de naissance
changer leur date de
naissance comme façon d'effacer les
traces on peut pas faire mieux et donc
ce que l'on disait à la Cour pénale
internationale et surtout au procureur
de la Cour pénale internationale il faut
que vous agissiez maintenant pour
envoyer un signal fort à Vladimir
Poutine et à sesbir pour qu'il cesse de
pratiquer cette politique et c'est ce
qui s'est passé s'attaquer à une
population
ciblée les enfants faire en sorte qu'il
perd toute trace ou tout lien biologique
affectif historique culturel avec leur
nation avec leur pays d'Ukraine vouloir
rayer ce lien de la surface de la terre
ça s'appelle un crime de de génocide
donc pour le moment pour que les choses
soient tout à fait claires le mandat
d'arrêt qui a été délivré contre
Vladimir Poutine et Madame Maria libova
est un mandat d'arrêt pour crime de
guerre s'agissant de la déportation des
de ces enfants en mais la Cour pénale
internationale elle est saisie de fait
et les qualifications peuvent changer le
résultat il a été atteint
aujourd'hui monsieur Poutine est
susceptible d'être arrêté dans n'importe
quel pays qui a ratifié le Statut de
Rome il est dans la situation d'un
fugitif c'est un délinquant et pas autre
chose il peut être à la tête d'une des
nations les plus puissantes du monde
elle est dirigée gouvernée par un
délinquent qu un présumé criminel qui
est en fuite dans son pays mais qui est
en fuite comme signal envoyé au despotes
autocrate tyran aux criminels les les
plus sanguinaires puisqu'on parle des
crimes les plus graves c'est un signal
très fort est-ce que ça va faire
disparaître les crimes tous les CRIM les
autocrates la réponse est non est-ce
qu'ils vont y réfléchir à deux fois je
pense que oui et surtout c'est la
mobilisation des opinions publiques
internationales évidemment des médias et
des des avocats et des avocates saisis
qui feront demain et après-demain si
malheureusement il y a des fait de de
cette nature à nouveau qu'on pourra plus
rapidement encore intervenir et demander
à la Cour pénale internationale de se
saisir des situation pour qu'elle puisse
agir efficacement qu'il s'agisse d'une
politique institutionnelle assumée par
le kremelin est-ce que ça renforce
justement ce chef d'inculpation de
génocide pour vous oui quand on voit que
Monsieur monsieur Poutine reçoit Maria
lebova h euh que celle-ci lui dit on a
un problème avec les enfants Ukrainiens
il faut modifier notre droit s'agissant
du régime d'adoption et que Monsieur
Poutine dit bah on va s'en occuper que
48 he après le problème est réglé ça
veut bien dire que c'est lui qui prend
les décisions quand madame Marie lbovas
qu'elle ne dit plus dorénavant dit j'ai
un chef c'est Poutine et elle l'a pas
dit une fois elle l'a dit 50 fois c'est
bien que les décisions s'agissant de la
déportation des enfants ukrainiens était
prise au kremelin quand on voit que tous
les moyens militaires de transport
étaient
organisé et centralisé pour assurer ce
transfert des zones de conflit en Russie
c'est bien qu'il y a une volonté
politique et une volonté politique du
kremelin et enfin quand on voit que
l'accueil de ces enfants est réalisé par
qui par les gouverneurs des régions
russes les gouverneurs ça correspond à
nos préfets et qu'à grand renfort de
médiatisation où tous les médias
officiels filmaient la scène de façon
très complaisante o en voyit ses enfants
à qui il ont filer des peluches et
cetera et avec des familles méritantes
russes on disait voilà vous avez ces
enfants à qui on donnait de l'argent
d'ailleurs voà qui était indemnisé c'est
qui était indemnisé c'est donc une
politique pensée réfléchie financé
institutionnalisé sur le plan logistique
et financier ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que ce sont les Russes qui ont
donné tous les éléments à charge contre
eux c'est incroyable c'est bien qu'on
était dans le sentiment d'impunité le
plus total et qu'on était aussi dans la
volonté d'envoyer un signal fort un
signal très très fort à l'opinion
publique russe en disant on va
dénasifier l'Ukraine et pour commencer à
dénasifier l'Ukraine il faut qu'on
commence par en quelque sorte exterper
des cerveaux des plus jeunes tout le
ferment antirusse de de de ceci et donc
on s'est attaqué au plus vulnérabl mais
c'est pas la première fois que ça se
passe dans mais alors justement cette
soi-disante politique de dénasification
avait déjà été mise en œuvre après
l'annexion de la créée en 2014 sans que
cela n'émeuve personne sans parler bien
évidemment de la tchenie de la Syrie en
quoi la donne a changé et pourquoi les
Occidentaux se réveillent si tard mais
écoutez ça ça s'appelle de la réelle
politique quand Poutine rase grosen
quand Poutine en Syrie rase Halep avec
des centaines de des dizaines voir des
centaines de milliers de morts tout le
monde pardon je vais le dire de façon
trifiale mais je vais le dire quand même
tout le monde s'en fout pourquoi parce
que d'un côté c'est des chechenen de
l'autre côté c'est des Arabes là la
donne a changé parce que la guerre est à
nos portes à 2h à 2h nous avons des des
Ukrainiens et des ukrainiennes de
comment dire de de confessions
chrétiennes orthodoxe
et là on commence à se dire c'est pas
possible et donc de façon
euh unanime on va se mobiliser pour dire
à Vladimir Poutine qu'il peut pas mener
cette guerre aux portes de l'Europe tant
mieux si ça permet de lutter contre
l'impunité mais il faut pas faire preuve
d'angélisme le cynisme et la règle d'or
en matière de relations
internationales monsieur Bachar al-Assad
qui était proscrit du banc des nations
aujourd'hui la Ligue arabe le reçoit et
il vient au au centre du jeu alors qu'il
a martyrisé sa population civile alors
vous savez ce que disait Michel Audiard
la justice c'est comme la Sainte Vierge
si on ne la voit pas de temps en temps
le doute s'installe beaucoup beaucoup de
chefs d'État ont échappé à leur juges
vous venez de le dire Bachar al-Assad
qui n'a jamais été inquiété la Syrie
n'ayant pas ratifié le Statut de Rome
d'autres pays les plus puissants se sont
bien gardés de le signer est-ce que
précisément on ne touche pas là à la
limite de l'exercice on touche là
peut-être à la limite de l'exercice mais
euh
les les chefs d'État sont pas chefs
d'État forcément à vie monsieur Bachar
al-Assad il sera s'il n'est pas tué je
souhaite pas sa mort il s'il n'est pas
tué avant il sera un jour traduit devant
une
juridiction ça peut être une juridiction
française sur une juridiction anglaise
néerlandaise ça sera peut-être la Cour
pénale internationale qui est saisie
également de la situation en Syrie nous
avons un
exemple Sloboda
il a été remis par qui il a été remis
par le gouvernement serbe la communauté
internationale a dit à
Serbie si vous voulez réintégrer le
concert des nations si vous voulez qu'on
vous aide pour la reconstruction du pays
il va falloir que vous donniez desgages
la lutte contre la corruption la
démocratisation de votre pays et il va
falloir aussi qu'on s'occupe de ceux qui
ont mené cette guerre et ce sont les
Serbes qui ont remis Slobodan milozevic
qui auraiit imaginé un an ou 2 ans
auparavant que le tout puissance le
Bodan miloevic allaer se retrouver dans
une cellule à personneou vous pensez que
ça pourrait se passer aussi pour
Vladimir Poutine parce que concrètement
comment juger un Vladimir Poutine alors
que les instances censées le juger
dépendent de pays qui ne reconnaissent
pas cette justice internationale et en
tout cas la courp pénale internationale
est saisie ce sont des crimes
imprescriptibles et les mandats d'arrêt
ne sont pas frappés de péremption alors
nous sommes en
2023 je ne sais pas ce qui se passera en
2024 en 2025 en 2030 mais Vladimir
Poutine
aujourd'hui n'est pas libre de ses
mouvements et je pense que s'il met un
pied dehors et si la situation évolue en
Russie il y aura le changement de la
donne et Vladimir Poutine sera jugé
peut-être d'ailleurs qu'on peut imaginer
moi je suis pas un politologue je suis
pas un spécialiste de la Russie on peut
même imaginer que pour ne pas avoir à le
déférer devant une juridiction pénale
internationale il soit jugé sur le
territoire russe mais justement est-ce
qu'on pourrait imaginer la création d'un
tribunal adhoc d'un tribunal spécial
habilité viable pour juger Vladimir
Poutine ou est-ce que seule la CPI
aujourd'hui a la compétence de juger
Vladimir Poutine aujourd'hui seul la CPI
a la compétence pour le juger mais les
Nations Unies peuvent décider de créer
un tribunal à Doc il y a beaucoup de
juristes qui demandent de la création de
ce tribunal à dooc pour accélérer le
cours de la procédure oui si ce n'est
que beaucoup de pays n'en veulent pas
parce que ils ont peur que cet
instrument juridique se retourne contre
eux oui et puis la France compris la
France comprise je ne milite pas pour la
création de ce tribunal à dog parce que
parce qu'il y a une juridiction qui
existe c'est la Cour pénale
internationale si on commence à la
déshabillé à la délégitimé à chaque fois
qu'il y a un dossier une affaire on va
pas y arriver mais il y a déjà des
tribunaux nationaux qui jugent à
coblance en Allemagne on a jugé un
militaire syrien le tribunal a argué de
sa compétence universelle donc des
tribunaux nationaux peuvent se
substituer au au tribunaux pénaux
internationaux c'est prévu dans le
Statut de Rome c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
une action complémentaire en France il y
a encore 15 dossiers concernant des
présumés génocidaires randais et qui
vont être jugés donc la compétence
universelle permet aux juridictions
national de ces pays de juger sur leur
territoire pour des crimes commis à
l'étranger des résidents de ces pays qui
se trouve sur le territoire français par
exemple et qui ont été interpellés sur
le territoire français d' et dans la
mesure où le TPIR le Tribunal
international pour le Rwanda a fermé ses
portes soit on les renvoie au Rwanda
pour qu'il soit jugés là-bas soit on les
juge ici je rappelle également que ceux
et celles qui sont jugés dans cpay sur
le fondement de la compétence
universelle ne sont pas les chefs d'État
mais la Cour pénale internationale AV
voocation à juger celles et ceux qui ont
assumé les plus hautes fonctions le
crime d'agression a été retenu pour la
première fois au procès de Nurenberg au
lendemain de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
qu'est-ce qui fait défaut aujourd'hui
pour qu'un tel procès se tienne
concrètement la volonté
politique j'ai pas d'autres réponse
céser disait qu'une civisation qui ruse
avec ces principes est une civilisation
moribonde ne pas juger cette agression
contre l'Ukraine reviendrait-t-elle
finalement à renoncer aux acquis de
nurenb
vraisemblablement et puis de toute façon
si l'on veut reconstruire la paix civile
si l'on veut reconstruire la Concorde si
l'on veut reconstruire le savoir-être le
savoir vivre entre entre les hommes et
les femmes que nous sommes si l'on veut
qu'il y ait une confiance qui se
restaure entre les États quels que
soient les dirigeants qui les ont
dirigés il faut nécessairement lutter
contre
l'impunité l'impunité l'injustice c'est
une plaie béante et de la gangraine et
tant qu'on l'a pas soigné tant qu'on l'a
pas traité c'est impossible d'avancer
donc c'est une nécessité si l'on veut
que les standards démocratiques soient
diffusés de façon plus unanime et plus
eff universelle et plus effective il
faut que les criminels soient jugés et
tout ce qui passe par des accord
d'arrière cuisine des des embrassades au
nom de la réale politique en fait ça
laisse une meurtrissure indélébil dans
ces populations qui a vu les photos de
de celui qu'on a appelé César ce
photographe officier qui avait pour
mission de photographier dans les
prisons syriennes les tortures les
tortures et les exécutions pour
documenter tous ceux qui avaient été
exécutés je vous assure si vous vous le
voyez une fois vous n'en dormez plus
pendant des semaines et c'est ce sont
des des choses qui vous poursuivent je
veux pas dire toute une vie je veux pas
être grandoquant mais franchement c'est
difficile quand on voit les charniers
rwandais c'est exactement la même chose
pour ceux et celles qui ont été à bcha
c'est on l'oubliera jamais c'est pas
possible donc pour que l'on puisse vivre
ensemble avancer ensemble se faire
confiance entre les États il faut que
justice passe comme l'ont dit alors
justement NBER c'est le maître étalon
d'une justice qui passe qui est
effective qui est viable qui fonctionne
c'est le maître étalon d'une justice qui
a fonctionné mais ça reste la justice
aussi des vainqueurs h euh les
États-Unis ont rasé Nagasaki
Hiroshima ce sont des crimes de guerre
et des crimes contre l'humanité qui ont
été commis en lâchant ces de bombes dres
a été rasé par les Alliés 500000 morts
que des civils c'est aussi à minim un
crime de guerre ce sont les Anglais les
Français les Russes les Américains qui
ont bombardé Dr on a pu juger les nazis
et on a pu juger les principaux
responsables mais on n'a pas fait le
ménage chez nous à l'époque alors est-ce
que c'était le prix à payer pour que
cette guerre cesse les historiens disent
oui les populations de l'époque parce
que c'est très facile en 2023 de donner
des leçons alors qu'on n' pas vécu cette
tragédie de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
mais quand on regarde les choses juste
sur le plan des principes euh c'est un
maîre étalon relatif Emmanuel Daoud ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que vous
travaillez prob Bono c'est vous
travaillez gratuitement pour ces ONG ces
associations est-ce que dans ces
dossiers ultra sensible comme celui
contre Vladimir Poutine subissez-vous
des pressions politiques ou
diplomatiques en l'état euh je n'ai subi
nous n'avons subi parce que je travaille
pas seul avec je travaille avec des
confrères et des consœurs nous n'avons
subi aucune aucune pression aucune donc
je vous je vous
réponds
directement la seule chose que l'on que
l'on doit faire lorsqu'on est lorsqu'on
traite ce type de dossier comme avocat
ou comme avocate c'est
d'essayer de prendre la parole de façon
pondérée et mesurée de pas raconter
n'importe quoi d'une part de pas être
dans l'imprécation et enfin de ne pas
nourrir ou laisser nourrir de faux
espoirs lorsque je dis que j'ai la
conviction que Vladimir
Poutine sera jugé un jour je le pense
vraiment lorsque j'ai dit queil serait
poursuivi c'est pas un motif de gloire
personnel mais c'est on m'a rayonné je
constate qu'il y a eu des mandats
d'arrêt et donc pour avancer dans le
combat contre l'impunité pour la justice
universelle et internationale il faut
avoir d'une certaine façon la foi du
charbonnier qu'est-ce qui vous fait P
mais justement qu'est-ce qui vous fait
penser qu'un jour Vladimir Poutine sera
jugé c'est votre votre
optimisme légendaire c'est mon optimisme
d'une part je sais pas s'il est
légendaire mais en tout cas c'est mon
optimisme et d'autre part parce que
c'est le sens de l'histoire on ne peut
pas se satisfaire d'une que les les
principaux responsables ne soient pas
jugés et si l'on veut nous mais aussi
les générations qui
viennent croire au fonctionnement de la
justice œuvre chacun et chacune dans ses
métiers dans ses professions pour éviter
que de telleles se reproduise il faut
bien qu'on se dise s'il y a un crime il
y aura une
poursuite évidemment avec le respect de
la présomption d'innocence et s'il y a
une déclaration de culpabilité il y aura
une
sanction que ça soit Poutine ou que ça
soit le brigadier chef Vladimir
prigonov qui était à boucha Emmanuel
Daoud pour vous ces poursuitite contre
Vladimir Poutine c'est l'engagement
d'une vie non je vais pas dire ça parce
que j'ai été saisi l'année l'année
l'année dernière mais vous avez été
aussi saisi de l'affaire du siècle de
l'inaction climatique contre l'État
français enfin ce qui est l'engagement
d'une vie ou en tout cas pour un avocat
ou une avocate c'est d'utiliser le droit
comme un outil de progrès social ça
c'est un engagement de faire en sorte
que l'on puisse ça peut paraître un peu
angélique ou un peu niet améliorer la
vie au quotidien des citoyennes et des
citoyens alors je vais le dire autrement
quand on poursuit un Poutine pour
génocide et crimes contre l'humanité
devient-on par la force des choses
l'avocat de l'humanité non non non il
faut rester à sa place moi je suis
avocat au barreau de Paris je traite les
dossiers euh avec sérieux et avec
humilité euh il faut pas se prendre pour
ce qu'on est pas euh donc voilà je suis
un avocat lambda qui travaille sur des
dossiers qui me sont confiés j'y attache
une importance particulière nous sommes
les les avocats dans notre cabinet de de
la Fédération internationale des Lig des
droits de l'homme depuis des des années
depuis le début des années 2000 nous
défendons d'autres ONG comme RSF MSF la
Fondation abépierre je le dis pas pour
tout ça gratuitement je je vais pas
revenir sur là-dessus
euh c'est parce que on veut le faire et
parce que les contentieux ou les actions
que nous menons au côté de ces ONG et de
ces associations fédérations sont des
ont des enjeux sociétaux et qu'il faut
utiliser le droit comme d'autres
utilisent la plume pour faire avancer
les choses est-ce que est-ce que vous
avit échangé avec l'ancien garde des
saau Robert Badinter à propos des
poursuites contre Vladimir Poutine parce
que à 95 ans il sait lancer dans ce
combat traduire le dictatur Russe devant
un tribunal pour crime contre l'humanité
je n'ai pas échangé avec lui j'ai
échangé avec l'un des des des auteurs de
de de l'ouvrage alors justement Robert
binter avec Bruno Cotte et Alain Pelet
ont dressé effectivement un réquisitoire
implacable somrement intitulé Vladimir
Poutine l'accusation à la fin de
l'ouvrage les auteurs reproduisent
inextenso des discours de vladir Poutine
j'imagine que ces discours pourraient à
eux seuls constituer des éléments à
charge non bien sûr ce sont des éléments
à charge h les vidéos que enregistré par
la télévision d'État russe et qui était
mise en ligne sur le site officiel du
kemelin où l'on voit monsieur Poutine
prendre des décisions comme commandant
en chef des forces armées sont des
éléments à charge je vais même aller
plus loin c'est une preuve
Emmanuel Daoud vous êtes un enfant
d'immigré diriez-vous qu'à ce titre vous
êtes plus sensible à la vulnérabilité et
à la
fraternité je je m'attendais pas à cette
question ça m'aime beaucoup votre
question question euh ce que je sais
c'est que je ne supporte pas euh
l'injustice je ne supporte pas pour
parler de notre pays le traitement qui
est réservé aux migrants aux réfugiés
aux exilés j'ai honte j'ai honte de du
démantellement de la jungle de Calais
j'ai honte que 700 gamins se soi
retrouvés dans une
école pendant deux ou 3 semaines privé
de tout parce qu'il n'avait pas de
refuge j'ai honte que la question de
l'immigration soit à ce point
instrumentalisée par les populistes de
tout poil oui j'ai honte et je pense que
nous devrions et pas simplement les
avocats tout le monde se regarder dans
une glace en disant mais
franchement quand on parle de solidarité
de fraternité est-ce que vraiment c'est
le cas en France et d'ailleurs puisque
vous parliez de Robert
Badinter on dit
souvent la France le pays des droits de
l'homme et Robert Badinter
répond non la France n'est pas le pays
des droits de l'homme la France c'est le
pays de la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose et la déclaration elle c'est pas
2022 est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les droits
humains sont respectés dans notre pays
s'agissant de certaines population la
réponse est NON et ça oui ça doit
révolter tout le monde de quel que soit
notre âge et quel que soit notre
profession merci merci infiniment